[Music]
hey everybody how's it going welcome to
a special video that we're doing here
talking about the seven deadly sins
celebrating 300 chapter of the seven
deadly sins I'm Anna Mack this is goals
and we're the two guys from the anime
Outdoor Channel you might be confused
you might think we're the same person a
lot of people do but we're actually two
different people that that's why we
sound different in different video at
the beginning we say either goes on or
Animax so that's how you know people
don't just get away right there and
joining us also is Knox Taku from the
Knox taco channel hey knocks hey what is
happening thanks for having me pleasure
man Knox is a good friend of mine a
decent friend of goes in and Knox is
also loving this Ark of the seven deadly
sins so we want we really wanted to have
him here and the several previous arts
as well we love where the manga is going
so we're gonna be talking about here
spoilers will follow about the seven
deadly sins manga because that's what
we're here to discuss so you know you
have been warned proceed with caution
and now one theme that I really want to
talk about here like I want to frame
this will talk about everything but I
want to frame it as a theme who is the
real Mellie Otis because we know that
meliodas before meeting elizabeth was
ruthless the most powerful of the demons
other than the demon king the most
ruthless and then suddenly he meets
Elizabeth he falls in love he becomes
completely different he betrays the
demon clan he goes on to be cursed and
you know he we meet him as he's cursed
in his you know childlike form
he seems like a friendly a fun-loving
guy but he has these flare-ups where he
destroys entire kingdoms and stuff like
that you know no big deal then we also
see him you know slowly losing his
emotions after he dies which makes him
more ruthless then he tries to become
the new demon king then he is possessed
by the demon king so I really want to
talk about this in particular who is the
real Mellie Otis and what where is the
story going what is me Leo's gonna be
like when the story ends but yeah so I
don't know goes and you got some
thoughts on this on this
yes so for me like it seems pretty clear
that when the purgatory is as emotions
right and the other part of him seems to
be this like killing machine this
perfect candidate for a demon king so
then the demon king just takes over that
body and that his emotions are obviously
don't agree so I'm wondering what
happens with the original rational
thinking Mele Otis is he just like fused
with the demon king right now and the
emotions are somewhere inside trying to
get out that's the question and they are
inside because he did escape from
purgatory and it was said that he's
going to be straight into the body so he
is somewhere inside that body it's just
right now he's being overpowered by the
demon king yeah and this was back in the
purgatory arc when the demon King's hand
was cut off and bond and melly Otis
managed to escape but our boy wild did
not yes any who knocks your thoughts
filled up one of those dastardly pigs oh
my god finally I mean yes rip wild rest
in peace good friend um so as far as
Mele Otis I agree with Gozen that
basically the emotional rational side is
the side of Mele Otis that really is
Mele Otis that's not in the middle of
this massive holy war where he's pitting
himself against millions of people
trying to kill them all
so I do think the series will end with
happy-go-lucky Milly oh jeez just a more
open one that would than we've seen
because throughout the anime he's always
like suppressing himself like always
keeping up that cheery facade even when
things are not necessarily going the
right way so when his facade cracks boom
goodbye Kingdom not cool so that's why I
love that training art with the Druids
because there I felt like that's the
first time we're really seeing millio
this and I think that's the Mele Otis
that we're gonna be left with at the end
of the series
yes rest in peace Dan afford them but
what I think is very interesting about
this whole thing is how do we then get
from the point where we are now
too many Otis gaining possession of
body again that's something that I'm
interested in very much so where is the
story going from here because we know
that lot to last we left off with
chapter 300 bond just showed up just in
time to save Hawk Hawk was all like a
yeah pod shows up steal the demon king
Adam a Liotta's goodbye yeah be very
late what yeah where does the story go
now because we know that bond is now
extremely powerful after being in
purgatory for centuries apparently right
the devil if you've counted and millenia
actually millennia thousands yeah we're
a thousand years at least that is insane
like you and imagine that then he comes
back and sees Kagan's like wait you look
like the worm from hunter hunter yeah
you got it in you got the reference in
so I had to you know we could move on
with our lives but but no I wonder
now what happens because bond is
obviously much stronger but he seems to
have given up his immortality
so that should theoretically make him
weaker now like well not necessarily
weaker yeah okay so again we'll see but
how do you guys think we get to the
current thing where melioidosis in an
adult form being possessed by the demon
king wrecking everybody at once like we
saw in the last chapter no one seems to
be able to stand out to him even though
we have mile with sunshine there we have
Ludo shall we have you know king powered
up King we have everybody know once
inside Ludo shells sucking balls
everyone else was like dead tired like
we all just fought like oh my god it's
the two art demon guys that are each
stronger than each of the commandments
by like five times what are we gonna do
and then like ah you thought this was
our final forms no and then they combine
into ultimate sinner guy and zelgius at
like 14 forms so like they're all pretty
tired out at this point they are I
understand why they would be beaten up
by Dean wad said to be fair the demon
king isn't even trying
that's like he's not even breaking a
sweat he didn't he didn't even have any
trouble his face was so composed all up
until bond showed up and his speed
actually got an expression to change on
his face so clearly he was not a
Expecting bonds at least speed and we're
probably gonna see that with his power -
did you want me to just go into my bond
thing yes so we're gonna we're working
over here right now above bond and how
strong he is because this is the big
question we've seen him like wreck a
bunch of like lesser demons after coming
out of purgatory we've seen him you know
to rescue Elaine but we have no idea how
strong he actually is and how he will
compare to demon king possessed meliodas
so yeah if you want to touch on that a
bit let's do it
so like with the videos gonna be in more
detail but here I'll touch on in a bit
we have a situation where now he's been
pumped up by the manga Mele always said
everyone will be shocked by how powerful
he is that he really got a lot more
powerful in purgatory the manga says
he's like the hope among everybody even
King with his new form like blonds gonna
be stronger than that and I think the
real secret to that power up is gonna be
the fact that his snatch ability was
always amazing he could steal power from
others and then he could use it himself
but he had a limit because his body
could only tolerate so much and what
they made clear in purgatory is that he
was broken down for like thousands of
years at least over a thousand years and
built back up to the point where his
body no longer actually was affected by
the frostbite or burns in purgatory
so his body grew in tolerance it's like
a hyperbolic time chamber on steroids
like instead of one year he has like you
know thousands and so what's gonna
happen now I think is that he's gonna be
able to steal much more power and so
he's gonna be able to steal not only
perhaps the demon Kings power but also
from all the other seven deadly sins
from mile from everybody and be able to
actually hold it in his body because now
he has that up like built up tolerance
and while most people can't use magic
against the demon king because of his
ruler ability that he can invert like
invert stuff
bond is the secret to beating that
because he can give the energy which
will actually take it away from the
demon king and if the demon king takes
off the ability they can actually do
damage on them excellent point because
as we learn from the purgatory arc if
you
giving magic to the demon king to
recover him or to help him it actually
hurts him because of his ruler ability
if it's activated oh yeah yeah and so if
he activates that bond right away knows
what to do and another thing is again
going back to the real Mellie Otis how
does can bond appeal to his emotions in
order to get him to regain control of
his body like while he's physically
fighting the demon king he's also like
bro Mellie Otis my buddy come on wake up
is that what's gonna happen do you think
well it might be like a Naruto kind of
thing where when Naruto kind of you
waste saw his own chakra then he needs
to start relying on the nine tailed fox
and that always something i tailed fox
can get in there and like take advantage
of his body so i'm thinking like if the
demon king wastes enough power perhaps
emilio toises emotions will have a
better chance of coming through okay so
he weakens his control yes knocks so I
agree with everything you said and that
would all be amazing because I love bond
but the only character in the entire
series I mean especially the seven
deadly sins that did not have their
themes their individual themes wrapped
up in this arc is Mellie Otis every
other character did to some degree so I
do think I don't know how because
there's no opponents left but Mellie
Otis will have some Buttkicker II going
on maybe even mentally against the demon
king he'll end up when all hope seems to
be lost power of friendship and stuff
and Mellie Otis all personally in his
mind have a fight with the demon king
and win but I don't know I I don't think
bond will be able to just take him down
one on one as much as I'd like to see it
because bonds new suit
is hype yeah you go to enemy upward
comms last shop or whatever scold and
pick up some feel the wrath thank you
for the plug it it wasn't us it wasn't
us and I'm a poor comm what I didn't say
it knock we won't rest until everyone
has
about 4 shirts both feel the wrath the
appraisal zone and we got to get a more
on one because bond is like one is one
of my favorite characters like I
possibly the favorite and I also love
Minnie Otis s Kannur and my Ella overall
his whole character arc not just mild as
he is now I think those are all amazing
characters and yes Sonakshi raised a
good point we have to see you know
Mellie Otis in action now that he's
being controlled by the demon king we
are not seeing him in action so are we
gonna see like a mental game where they
show it like it's actually happening
with in his mind he is fighting the
demon king but they show it as a real
fight or you said we might not have any
more opponents left but but I think that
we might actually have the Guptas head
no I think we might actually have you
know the the demon king and the supreme
deity in their original bodies they
could theoretically be the final
opponents so if meliodas regains control
of his body the demon King's like okay
that's it now I'm gonna destroy this
whole world supreme deity does something
- and then they all have to get together
and fight these like godlike creatures
yeah be dope but as far as big fights
I don't even necessarily care if Mellie
Otis gets to flex his muscles and beat
some big guy every character completed
their character arc I mean like you have
King always felt bad about himself like
he was the inferior guy in the group at
all times and in this arc he became a
total beast and saved the day or like
esken or esken or was the always this
prideful but I've mentioned he he fought
esta rosa and destro said the power of
all the food robe so basically since he
didn't even hate esta rosa he watched
this roast like kill Melly odors in
front of his own eyes
belly Otis was his Savior dude he did
not hey testa Rossa
at all he's just pity him this prideful
bastard and later Mile
who is mr. OSA for the past two rulers
after he caught s Canora snores like I
can't do this dude it's all on you
and that is the most selfless thing
possible he didn't just you know let his
friends die and he gave up his power
2-mile who would do a better job with
that power so everyone and Bond bunch
popped up out of purgatory and he's the
sin of greed and his power is gift I
mean that's pretty of is but so Mellie
Otis is gonna have some wrath like thing
where he can utilize his wrath in a
better fashion he's gonna have a big
moment but I don't know what it is and
that's why we're reading the manga not
reading fanfics thanks for coming yeah
no I mean I'm loving the manga like
seven deadly sins is a battle Shonen so
you know you're expecting a lot of
action and you're not necessarily
expecting a ton of you know character
development or you know intense
backstory or anything that but we
definitely get that with the seven
deadly sins which is amazing so we
coupled that action with that and
especially later on in the manga like at
first I always say this in the first
season of the anime in the first
chapters of the manga we don't know the
backstory of Nami honest we don't know
the backstory of bond or anyone but as
we quickly have slowly learned those
stories that's when I really started
loving this series and now this arc
feels like everything is coming together
as you said knocks everyone is like
fulfilling their purpose and learning
these important life lessons for their
characters and developing and it's just
been so great but them and you're right
I think and that is why I wanted to you
know talk about the real Mellie Otis
because Mel Yoda still hasn't had his
you know complete arc he was for you
know this ruthless demon then somehow
just from falling in love with Elizabeth
he suddenly becomes much more kind
betrays the demons we don't know exactly
how this happened we might learn more
about this I'm not sure now he decides
and this was really cool I think he
decides that in order to break the curse
to own Elizabeth he has to give up his
emotions give up who he is now in order
to you know be able to absorb the
commandments become the next demon king
and have enough strength to break the
curse so he abandons the seven deadly
sins he's the cat and he says the seven
deadly sins are no more I have to become
the demon king
so that is big
so we're thinking okay so now this
malleolus is willing to give up
everything he believes in just so he can
save Elizabeth kind of like bond was
willing to kill Mellie Otis to save a
lane and came to regret it
of course so the question is now what
will Mellie Otis do will he allow the
demon king to control him while he rebel
against it somehow how will you know how
will he come into play here it's and I I
loved I'm getting all excited here but I
loved how absorbing the 10 commandments
turned out to be a trap yeah something
had to happen right like we couldn't we
couldn't just have him come back with
his emotions and everything be fine well
then he could have therapy fought the
demon king in his original body but I
think that it's so interesting it's like
everyone's saying if you absorb all the
10 commandments you can rival the demon
king you can challenge him and in
reality you become a vessel force demon
king the demon king had it all planned
out 3,000 years ago I thought that was
pretty awesome that was good when you
wonder women and gentle women why didn't
he just give all the Ten Commandments to
zelgius and sell just comes into the
human world and boom demon king is there
haha mere mortals no but he didn't think
of it well maybe this whole evil plan
dividing up the commandments yeah yeah
well we see that's a good question
because I think it's because and we had
a Rhema the loser in the chat asked what
why do we think that the demon Kings
body is actually weaker than Mele Otis's
body we don't know but it's clear that
the demon king has aged like he appears
as an old man with a beard Mele Otis
appeared like almost childlike melody
appears an adult so it is possible that
the demon king wants a younger body and
also a body that's not stuck in
purgatory and it is also possible that
he just doesn't think zelgius is up to
it whereas meliodas he thinks has that
potential also the destroyer for some
reason that's like a special thing that
Mele Otis is mm-hmm a destroyer and that
means something yes so there's something
special in execution what that means
something too
not enough not only kills one person
well the oldest I think there's
something special bottom he has some
potential that maybe zelgius doesn't and
that is
why this trap was set for him because I
feel like you and the fact that the
curse was placed on Elizabeth that was
the driving force for meliodas to keep
getting stronger and to try to absorb
the commandments right so it's almost
like the demon king planned it all out
if that's true then it's feeling too
much black zetsu like Naruto
oh I planned everything all along
putting all the pieces together pitting
everyone against them so that this exact
thing can happen 14 generations later
yeah it possible like I think he hedged
his bets cuz he was okay like either way
if it didn't turn out this way
but if it did he had a back-up plan but
I don't want a pretty crappy back-up
plan 3000 years of real life time that's
how long he spent in purgatory yeah
we're having like hundreds of millions
of years hundreds of millions of years
this old dude is sitting in this
blistering cold and hot garbage waiting
in this vat of molten crap hoping that
Mellie Otis will lose his mind I don't
know I don't buy that I hope that's not
the case well who knows weird because
because the thing is we don't know if
the demon Kings body is deteriorating we
don't know if he's 100% immortal or if
there's something that he has to account
for so we'll see we'll have to see it
the manga definitely wants the younger
body like he's emphasized that so he's
probably not immortal or at least and he
can't like go on like this forever and
he's weakened he's probably like not a
good vessel like he needs Mellie Otis
for that but yeah she is do you think he
has a demon king is like can he get his
purgatory salt into the real world like
now are they together or is he still I
don't have a I'm in purgatory once half
of heaven Mellie Otis what I was
thinking is potentially one of the big
fights will firmly Otis would be the
meliodas in purgatory beating the demon
king in purgatory and that somehow
affecting what's going on outside of
purgatory
yeah the only thing is he escaped
purgatory it led us to believe it led us
to believe but it was very unclear
Vaughn lost him transferring out like I
don't know exactly yeah my thinking and
this is my hypothesis if it turns out
that the demon king is still partially
in purgatory then the final villain will
be the demon king in his huge form if it
turns out that he was completely
transferred then perhaps not but again I
feel like we still need to learn about
the supreme deity like we've almost seen
her not at all so do you think the
series could end without her coming into
play I do not know it may potentially be
a new arc or saga oh that would be
amazing because I don't want this to end
I don't want this to end
yeah but one thing I have to say the
demon king is an absolute mad lad he
worked out this incredible genius plan
with the supreme deity he's like supreme
baby here's the thing curse my bastard
son meliodas
give him immortality and I'll curse
Elizabeth so she keeps reincarnating so
the MLE Odinson is like turmoil and
stuff wink wink and supreme deities like
great plan demon king guys amazing so
they each curse each other's kids now
demon king guy comes out uh takes the
curse off Elizabeth and meanwhile he has
the all immortal body of Lily Otis thank
you god is famine very cool yeah so the
thing is we don't know the relationship
between the demon king and the supreme
beauty you know is there some connection
between them are you know what was their
whole reason behind cursing that their
two children supposedly right is it all
just
oh we were mad or is it all is it
something more I noticed something when
I was reading the manga recently and it
was one of those question corners for
knockabout where he answers questions
and someone asked are Mele Otis's
brothers do they have a mother
this is Mellie Otis and his brothers how
a mother and knocking about sudden I
would think so and yet this interesting
thing is I'm pretty sure they asked this
after mile was revealed to be like not
like supposedly not his brother
but I goddess so like it would suggest
he didn't correct him so it would
suggest he has multiple brothers but the
idea is there is definitely
there there's definitely a mom it's just
we haven't met her yet
he doesn't just like demon king doesn't
just reproduce asexually so yeah so
goddess like it makes sense you know
what I mean it has sailed ladies and
gentlemen supreme deity and gotten demon
king hell yeah
I read like who else really hang I ship
it secret meetings in purgatory
you know weekends off for the supreme
deity yeah well the thing is that I
think the fact that as you said that
they have a mother or knock about Sookie
thinks they have a mother but isn't no
it's important yes because I it could be
just the demon king oh he just creates
them out of clay and breathes life into
them or whatever but no that's not the
case they seem to have a mother so I
feel like that should come into play and
again we don't know exactly when the
manga will and everything is gearing up
towards that you know an ending where
sucks but I wanted to keep going because
there's so many unanswered questions
about Merlin about the original goals or
about the supreme deities so much stuff
dude that go through thing needs to be
explained it needs to be expounded on
there has to be something there yeah
that was pretty lame like my ultimate
plan to confuse everyone to raise
everyone's mind why do I do this you ask
I'm not telling you okay come on man let
us in on the secret
this whole cool feel with Estero stood
for nothing no I'm sure there's gonna be
something and it's gonna be interesting
and I've been looking forward to finding
out the whole secret of goal third all
go through original goal through holy
wars I think there's you know every new
chapter right now reveals like insane
information yeah a lot of new stuff yeah
so if it keeps like this like we'll have
endless videos tonight
so to sound up Oh sound up roundup
roundup
to both of those together above this
whole reel meliodas arc I think Knox you
hit the nail on the head when you said
we still have to see Melly Otis come
full circle we've seen this character
evolve drastically throughout the series
and we now need to see him
full circle from a guy who is fun-loving
and stuff in order to control his power
you know he's afraid he wants to bubble
it all down he wants to suppress it so
that he doesn't lose control but then he
ends are bubbling up and he loses
control like with Danna for to someone
who needs to come full circle embrace
his original magic his original power
and control it and still be himself and
I think that is going to be definitely
where we're heading next and I can't
wait I'm excited you guys agree I agreed
that he is agree that anime excited I
also agreed that I he'll have to learn
how to deal with his dark self and not
try to constantly suppress it because
that doesn't end up well I will say
though for some reason though he
believes if you use this his original
power he won't be able to stay in the
human world so we'll have to see what he
means by that yeah and that could be a
foreshadowing that the final showdown
might happen either in purgatory or the
demon realm or something and we know
nothing about the demon realm either
everybody there's a demon realm yes
there is a demon realm and a celestial
realm and we haven't even gone there yet
yet I eighteen more arcs and I'll be
happy
handy less and hanomag will riot yeah
that concludes this portion of our
discussion now we can move on to the Q&A
if you want to watch the Q&A portion of
this discussion or if you want to tune
in live in future weeks because we're
gonna be doing these types of
discussions weekly be sure to follow
anime up or on Twitch link in the
description also don't forget to
subscribe to the NMR / YouTube channel
for more 7 Deadly Sins content and
finally please show the mad lad NOx talk
with some love by subscribing to his
YouTube channel linked in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see our space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]